le visage du quartier Notre-Dame
changera complètement toutes ces maisons
à proximité de la fonderie ont une
seront détruites il s'agit des citoyens
les plus touchés par les émissions de
contaminants provenant de l'entreprise
un choc mais aussi un soulagement pour
François et sa conjointe qui habite
cette maison depuis maintenant 22 ans
oui c'est un soulagement mais c'est
encore un stress par rapport à ce qui
sentent
toutes ta vie qui est au milieu
ce locataire est très inquiet car les
logements dans ce quartier sont les
moins chers à Rouyn-Noranda je vais
mettre enfant avec mon frère en
colocation parce qu'on va se dire le
prix des loyers assez dispendieux fait
que on s'entend ça c'est un autre espèce
de plus de trouver un logement déjà
c'est compliqué de trouver une place
certains commerçants s'inquiètent de
perdre leurs clientèle c'est une
clientèle régulière même
assez grosse clientèle je te dirais que
ça va assez loin mais quand on déménage
un emploi un commerce on y pense
d'autres comme la directrice générale de
cette friperie en profite pour réclamer
d’être eux aussi relocalisés on est
carrément dans leur cours on a comme
arrière court la fonderie on est
vraiment vraiment collé puis ça serait
difficile à comprendre et pour
l'administration et pour les employés
que nous on nous laisse là dans un
espèce de no man's land inhabité le
gouvernement nous sera aussi que
l'entreprise devra réduire ses émissions
à 15 nanogrammes par mètre cube
d'arsenic dans l'air annuellement d'ici
5 ans c'est 5 fois plus que la norme
québécoise de 3 à Québec tous les
parties de position estiment que le
gouvernement n'en fait pas assez la CAC
préfère
déménager 200 familles plutôt que mettre
au pas une multinationale milliardaire
les entreprises qui polluent doivent
elles-mêmes corriger leur processus mais
on peut pas avoir l'ambition d'être de
dépasser cinq fois la norme dans un cas
le ministre de l'Environnement Benoît
charrette sera à rouen-noranda Juan
l'après-midi pour présenter en détail ce
qui sera autorisé à la fonderie un en
terme d'émission au cours des cinq
prochaines années et les gens de
roneranda ici ont beaucoup de questions
à lui poser ici Jean-Marc Belleville
Radio-Canada